what's up ken good morning so i'm 29
years old
um i've kept quite a dark secret all
these years
um and you're honestly the first this is
the first time i've really ever even
spoke of this
so um i've seen counselors and
therapists
not too many over the years but in my in
my 20s i've seen a couple
and i still never had the courage to
really talk of it um
so now i've just it's been eaten at me
all these years and i've just decided
that
because my life is where it's at right
now and some of the habits and the
problems i face day to day i feel like
because of this
problem i face as a child that it might
have something to do with it so
basically what happened
hey but hold on hold on before you
before you tell me what you're about to
tell me
that's quite the setup here so
why me why did you choose to whatever's
been hanging on for
30 years now three decades why now why
me
well because you know i've really
enjoyed seeing you on dave ramsey's show
i've really
taken a liking to the things that you
have to say to callers
and i like your insight and i feel like
saying this over the phone
and not face to face to somebody i don't
know at all
was a little bit easier okay all right
well i
don't know where you're about to head
with this but i appreciate your trust
and
go for it so so tell me what's what
you've been sitting on
so basically when i was about four or
five years old
um i was sexually molested by my older
brother for
quite some time oh man i'm so sorry
thanks and it just
it was so weird i remember it so vividly
but at the same time it's so foggy
um i don't know if my family
really knows about it i i think they do
um i have four older brothers i'm the
youngest of five boys
and uh i just i remember it happening
over and over while i shared a room with
my older brother and i don't know
why we shared a room i don't i don't
understand it because we
were he's the second oldest and i'm the
youngest so i don't really know how that
worked out or whatever but i do recall
it just
ending one day it just ended what was
the age difference between you and your
brother
um so he is
seven and a half years older than me
okay
so nothing too significant but well
that's a lot that's a whole whole lot
um especially if you're talking about
three four and five
and ten eleven and twelve that's a big
big gap
what makes you think that folks in your
family knew or know about this
um because i just remember i remember it
ending abruptly one day
um and i and i i had this vision i'm not
sure if it's a dream of this vision but
i remember
my mom yelling at my older brother at
one moment because i feel like maybe
another brother of mine
kind of found out or saw what was
possibly going on and then told my mom
but i never spoke to my mom about it i
never spoke to anybody about it
and my mom has since passed away and
i i get really upset that i never talked
to her about it
and i don't want to bring it up to
anybody now especially my brother
because of how
awkward it may be or how you know i feel
like he's kept us inside too
you know so so as we dig into this
i need you to remember one key important
thing
somebody took something from you
and from this point forward you are in
control of the narrative
you are in control of the way this plays
out
okay and
i want you to know that it's noble and
kind to think about his
his feelings it's noble and kind for you
to think about
what he might be going through but the
reality is
people who suffer abuse at the hands of
loved ones
often spend their life trying to make
sure everybody else is okay
yeah and the one person they don't make
sure is okay is them
and so i'm giving you permission you
don't need my permission but i'm giving
it to you anyway
that it's time for you to start caring
for you
okay okay i mean it sounds like over the
years you've dabbled in
talking to professionals you've hemmed
and hauled around it
because you know you weren't well you
knew something was gone on your inside
and um now it's time to decide whether
you know what the way things are just
having said it out loud on the radio in
front of millions of people
that's out there i feel better now or
you're gonna go be about
healing and that may or may not end up
in sitting down and talking with your
brother about what happened
so circling back
now that you know like you're in control
you've said it out loud
there's several traumas here one is yeah
being sexually abused by your
someone who loves you your older brother
that's big
number two almost as bad if not
worse because again your brother's 11
your brother's 12 your brother's
you know 13 during this stuff not
letting him off the hook but he also is
a child
right right as bad if not worse
is the thought that my adult mom knew
this was happening and
didn't do anything or my adult mom
did know this was happening she put a
stop to it but never stopped to ask me
if i was okay
right and ken that's not okay
that that happened to you that's wrong
and that sucks
totally and so you've said it out loud
and i know you've i'm just assuming here
you have fantasized about that
conversation with your mom
you fantasize that conversation about
your brothers with your brothers
you fantasize about having a
conversation with the actual brother who
hurts you
so i ask you this what do you want to do
um well getting the courage to speak to
you today about this was was difficult
enough but i do feel like a weight has
fallen off my shoulders
um do you feel i really do you feel
different than before you said that out
loud
yeah describe that to people listening
because there are millions of people
who have suffered things that can't
bring themselves to say it out loud
and people don't realize what it feels
like to just set that cinder block
down for a second yeah
i mean i really feel like i was just
carrying a backpack full of cinder
blocks all these years i really do and
and it's just
it feels really good to just say it out
loud i've kept this secret suppressed
for all these years my entire life
essentially
yeah and just saying it it makes me feel
like a whole different person
well i appreciate your your trust here
man i appreciate your bravery
and so going back what do you want to do
now
um well i haven't given it a whole lot
of thought because i never thought i'd
really get the courage to tell you yeah
but i do
i do feel like i want to discuss this
with
with at least my other brothers first
before i approach the brother that did
this to me
because i'm a little closer to my other
brothers than i am him
um but i i really don't know i i really
don't want to
my dad's still around and alive but i
really don't want to talk to him about
it we're not very close anyway but i
would like to approach my other brothers
and just see if it's something that they
were ever aware of or
you know but i really don't want to
drive a wedge between
my brother and the other ones you know
either
and so a couple of things here number
one you're not driving a wedge
that wedge was driven by somebody else
okay and it's not your responsibility to
continue to make sure your other
brother's okay
it is important to remember that he was
a child too
right right but the wedge has been
driven
okay i want to ask you what do you want
to accomplish by having the conversation
and there's not a right or wrong answer
to this
but do you want ultimately him to say he
was sorry
do you want him ultimately to
acknowledge that he hurt you and that he
wished he hadn't
what are you hoping to get to do you
want to see him go to jail
what do you what do you want to see
happen
i don't want anything negative to happen
to him and i certainly don't
expect an apology because i realize he
was a child as well
i guess my main motivator would be to to
figure out if this was possibly
or excuse me if this event that happened
had any bearing on the way i am today as
far as
my own issues you know my own sexual
problems that i may face today with
with my own self it you know did that
event have any
any cause on this the way i am
so what sexual problems do you have now
well
growing up i always had this thought of
teeter-tottering on whether or not i was
gay right you know i never i never felt
the urge per se but i always thought
maybe i was
yep um i've never never done anything
physical with another man but i've
always had that thought like maybe i am
and i've always had girlfriends i have a
girlfriend now
and uh you know i always thought what if
i'm bisexual what is this what if that
because
because of this event because it screwed
up my whole head yeah
um you know i have porn i have porn
addiction pornography i watch
often um you know i i somewhat abuse
alcohol
not terribly but i somewhat abuse it i
have an addictive personality
yeah so i just wonder if these issues
are because of this
i i think it's a futile exercise to look
for
a particular pinpoint cause of
x and y and z i also think the answer to
all those questions is going to be in
some shape form or fashion yes
one of the most damning things about
sexual abuse about abuse of any kind
is it makes you start doubting yourself
it plants all kinds of different
questions and seeds in your heart and
mind
that wouldn't have been there in the
first place
and it fractures
connection because it weaponizes
relationships right
your body begins to associate closeness
in love with hurt and the only thing
that keeps us well
is relationships that's it
and that's the demon that's the forest
fire that will rage through family
trees for years is disconnection
that makes us anxious and it makes us
depressed and it makes us
look to shut off those alarms with
varying sorts of addiction and you just
name several of them right
it makes us not trust ourselves and
spend our whole lives performing to make
sure everyone around us is okay
and it's exhausting right oh big time
yeah and so
here's you can take this for what it is
you
have permission to do whatever you want
to do in this situation
okay mm-hmm
before you go meet with your other
brothers
i would recommend sitting down with a
with a counselor that you trust and
being honest for the first time
being absolutely honest
i would have i want you to to
mention to that counselor your plan to
go to your other brothers before your
your the offending brother
without knowing more about your family
dynamics and again we only have 10
minutes or 15 minutes here on the radio
i feel like going directly to that
brother after you've got some healing
and some
some very specific questions to ask that
you can work through with
a trauma counselor and again this isn't
a lifetime event
i think you can go meet with somebody um
and get through some specifics
i think you can meet with somebody and
get to some specific
questions and goals very quickly you're
a real articulate guy you've obviously
thought through this for a long long
time
but i want you to recognize what's about
to happen to you okay
you put this out there you've said it
now
once you take the lid off this thing
you're going to be filled with
rage that you've been keeping down for a
long long time
you're going to be feel you're going to
have rage and it's going to spew at
everybody okay you are going to
continue to look at every single
disagreement in your life
and want to blame and push and point
some of that will be accurate some of it
won't
and you're gonna feel things that you
haven't ever felt because they've been
buried underneath this deal okay that's
why it's
real important to have somebody to walk
with you during this next season
okay and it's not a life again it's not
a lifetime of
you're going to be in therapy for the
rest of your life that doesn't mean that
you're not going to heal relationships
but it does mean that by taking the
cover off this thing you're gonna have
to deal with some stuff you haven't
dealt with
you're probably gonna have some regrets
that you've made in your life that
you're gonna have to work back through
and forgive yourself for
and you might need to end up calling
your girlfriend and saying i'm sorry
about some things
letting her in on this conversation
right
right but at some point
sitting down with your offending brother
if he'll have the conversation
when you're ready to rock and roll that
may be real healing for you and after
meeting with a counselor and talking
through specifically what happened
going through a trauma narrative
learning some some
coping skills that don't involve
pornography that don't involve alcohol
that don't involve
yelling and flying off the handle or
whatever other challenges you experience
you may realize dude i'm not gonna have
a conversation with him there's no need
to
there's no need to right i'm not gonna
get the closure i was looking for
i'm not gonna get the apology that i
desperately want or maybe you will
right right but
that's true but i want you to keep in
mind you're in control of
how this plays out but i also want you
to keep in mind
that now that you've said it out loud
there's going to be some
some instant release some instant
like you said bricks down you're going
to put those center blocks on the ground
and now the real work is going to start
because now you've acknowledged it
and i want you to be a good steward of
you ken
i want you to love my buddy ken for the
first time
and i want you to start by asking
somebody who's a professional to walk
alongside you and
you got to be honest with them
i will certainly do that okay
i'm i really appreciate it i'm proud of
the call i'm proud of your bravery
and if you are just walking out to take
the trash out tonight and you burst out
into tears i want you to know that's
okay
and if your girlfriend calls tonight and
says hey i can't
i can't get together tonight let's do it
tomorrow and you just
fill rage race through your body i want
you to know that's okay
it's how you handle it on the back end
that's that's gonna determine character
right
but now you're just taking step one of a
long healing process
okay okay as you make your way through
this
i want you to reach out to me ken i want
to know how the conversation with a
counselor goes
i want to know a couple of like a month
from now a couple weeks from now
as you begin to wrestle with this and
you start to imagine sitting down
at a table in your living room with your
brother
what that conversation will be like
and let's keep talking let's keep
talking because i want to hear how this
thing plays out
i want to honor your bravery brother and
man i'm proud of you for saying it out
loud
i'm proud of you for taking that cinder
block out of your backpack that somebody
else put in there
and just setting it down setting it down
not caring anymore
my hope is that the spring returns to
your step a spring that you may have
never known ken
and you're able to connect with your
girlfriend you're able to
stop having intimacy with
fantasies with people on a computer and
you're able to have intimacy with real
people in real life
and that's gonna be a process you're
gonna have to learn how to do that
you're gonna be able to quit drinking
when you get scared quit drinking when
you feel alone
you quit drinking when you feel shame
and be able to lean into real people and
you're gonna have to learn how to do
that
because that was taken from you at a
young age
and i hope that you get to a place of
forgiveness
and that's the last final brick to set
down
but the healing starts today my brother
and i'm proud of you ken i'm proud of
you
we'll be thinking about you we'll be
praying for you and your family my
friend